at this point I want to introduce you to
Portia Burton she's going to be doing
our next talk she is the founder of her
own company plb analytics and she's
going to be talking to you about knowing
thy neighbor so are you okay that's
speaking yes I do oh there we go um
hello once again my name is Portia
burton and i am going to forewarn you
that this is going to be a very beginner
lesson on scikit-learn and K&N so a
little bit more about me I am organizer
of the Portland data science group or a
great group of local people who talk
about data visualization we talk about
database technologies and we have a lot
of fun together I'm also volunteer of an
organization called hack organ heck
Oregon takes some campaign data and we
make it more accessible for people who
are interested in committees and
campaigns and how money is flowing in
the political system and finally as you
already know I'm also a founder of a
company of company called plb analytics
we're going to cover a lot today so
let's get to it brief introduction to
machine learning the first thing that
we'll talk about we'll go over the
Python machine learning package
scikit-learn will explain the k-nearest
neighbor algorithm in a bit more detail
we'll have a demo of scikit-learn and
cannon will explore it a sample script
and the next step not going to talk
about the next step yet so machine
learning what is machine learning simply
it's when the alga libram is learning
from the data that you're giving it
it's responsive to the data on the
algorithms use the data to create
predictive models to classify unknown
entities that's something that we will
be doing today and discover patterns and
this is just a sample of some of the
things that you can do machine learning
there are others as other activities as
well here is a baked basic workflow of
machine learning oh this is basically
how I do my work seventy percent of my
time is spent cleaning and standardizing
the data twenty percent of my time is
spent pre-processing training validating
and then comes the fun part which is a
ten percent no no this is cool or i get
to analyze and visualize and pre 10 i
know d 3 javascript scikit-learn so once
again scikit-learn is pythons answer to
machine learning it's great it's um
machine learning package it has great
documentation actually a lot of this
presentation is basically an ode to
scikit-learn documentation and it has
built-in data sets so if you're new to
machine learning and you don't want to
go out and hunt for your own data set on
you can use the data sets provided for
you by decide kit learn documentation
such as a Boston housing market however
after the presentation if you're
interested in hunting data sets then I
actually have some places that you can
go to I spent a lot of time hunting data
sets let's say that you have this is a
great illustration that you will find in
the documentation let's say that you're
given a machine learning task and you do
not know exactly where to begin this
would be great in helping you figure out
what you should do so a question you
should ask yourself is how big is your
data set
if you have less than 50 samples then
you should probably go and get some more
data if you can and you have to figure
out what do you want to do I mean what
kind of problem do you have do you have
a classification problem clustering
regression or dimensionality reduction
once you figure out what your problem is
then you can play around with the
different algorithms for today we are
going to deal with a classification
problem and the person presenting Sarah
the person presenting after me you'll
get a chance to see what to do during a
clustering problem many companies
organizations not-for-profits use
scikit-learn one of them being Evernote
Evernote on you're familiar with
Evernote basically you can take a
website and turn it into a note when you
turn it into a note you have the option
of putting it inside a notebook before
you put it inside a notebook Evernote
tries to make a guess on which notebook
to put it in that is suggesting
notebooks is a classification problem
and it implements the naive based
classification algorithm I should say
Evernote did you scikit-learn I think
Evernote actually uses Java now it's in
there they have a blog post about it you
can read it later here is naive Bayes
classification okay and if you're
beginning with a saw machine learning
you might you will come across
supervised and unsupervised learning
unsupervised learning is simply when the
data points are not labeled with
outcomes if you're looking for bins put
it in you the patterns are actually
found by the algorithm as opposed to buy
the person so supervised learning which
is what we're going to do today your
samples are ready labeled there are two
different types of
supervised learning there's a
classification where you have
categorical data and there's also
regressions regressions usually
regressions use continuous data and here
is the theoretical model for supervised
learning supervised learning you take
your features you pick the features that
you feel are the most predictive and
using those features you're able to come
up with an outcome remember when you are
making your model to keep your sample
size hi but you want to keep your
feature set low you want to keep your
sample size high but your feature set
low because you want to prevent
overfitting and noise here are some
examples of supervised learning that you
might have come across handwriting
analysis spam filters oh I'm glad you
find it amusing and now it's time to
talk about the kank nearest neighbor
algorithm the k-nearest neighbor
algorithm is considered the simplest
machine learning algorithm it is a lazy
algorithm which means it does it's not
active and it doesn't run computations
on a data set until you give it a new
data point that is not true for all
machine learning algorithms and our
examples will use KN for supervised
learning problem number one mystery
fruit let's say you have several apples
and several oranges and you have an
unclassified fruit in this case we are
going to set our k23 we're going to look
at our three nearest neighbors
using this information we are going to
predict or we're going to identify our
mystery fruit so using this using ks3
our mystery fruit is most likely yes an
orange pro tip whenever you're setting k
please try to use an odd number you
don't want to be in a situation where k
is for and you have two apples and two
oranges and you're not sure arm which
one to identify which one to use so keep
your k naam keep your cave odd for the
most part majority vote there are two
ways that you can control majority vote
majority vote can be equal weight which
means each Kanan neighbor has an equal
weight or could be distanced weight
distance weight is where each KNN
neighbors vote is based on distance
Kanan uses vacuum theorem so yes middle
school math is useful after you graduate
here the downside of KNN downsizes since
there is minimum training there is a
high computational cost and testing new
data and the correlation can be falsely
high which means the data points can be
given too much weight live demo time
before we do our demo I hate to break
the flow of this presentation but do you
have access to my github repo yes did
you already clone the materials yes
great okay so if you can just go to the
can n um Oh were you not given a link ok
of course not ok
okay so if you go to this link you'll
get the materials for this presentation
I'm sorry and give that to you earlier
and all you need to do is I get clone
and that will give you the ipython
notebook so I'll give you about other be
several minutes to clone materials
you
so you're doing oh so what you got yes
yes thank you thank you yeah yes I'm not
sure exactly where it is but it is in
documentation where you can find out how
long it takes I've done yeah but um no
it's in there and we can look for that
afterwards everyone so is everyone able
to get the notebook up and running yes
okay so you're looking for a que we're
going to go to KN n PI con 2014 really
that's interesting okay oh yes idea so
PI data 2014 yes critical mass good
so I hope I have your attention some of
you that's okay I'll take some our data
set we're going to use irises some of
you will say oh no not irises iris is
actually a classical data set that if
you've dealt with machine learning then
you've come across this let's give some
I'll give you some information about the
iris dataset it's typical and it's
actually older than Python older than
you it was actually created in 1936 it
was analyzed by sir ronald fisher but it
was collected by Edgar Anderson so
that's a little bit of historical
information about the famous iris
dataset our job is to classify which
type of iris that we have based on the
length and the width of the sepal and
the pedal and to give away the ending
this is what you should have when you
run the old code the blue the dots are
actually the training data and the pink
green and lilac is where your decision
points your decision lines or locate it
that's your test data so your any other
information I should give you and these
are the different type of viruses that
we have in our data set at this point
we're going to go to ipython to PI data
2014
we have over packages dumped I pylab
matplotlib scikit-learn we are going to
set our neighbors to 30 and we are going
to load our data set which is the iowa
state asset yes you're right thank you
thank you that was a test no it wasn't
at all it was an honest mistake thank
you so 31 and we're going to load our
iris dataset and what I like to do is
we're actually going to print the shape
of our data set the X information gives
you um how many samples were dealing
with and two is telling you how many
features were looking at so we're
looking at two features we're going to
create our mesh and in this section we
are going to classify we're going to fit
our data set and then we're going to
predict and after we set our x and y
axes mala
now if you notice figure 1 and figure 2
is different and the reason why there's
a difference is because of our parameter
weights in one in figure 1 our weight is
uniform and in figure 2 our weight is
distance so what I'd like you to do is
we're going to break the rule again
actually I would like you to set your
neighbors to 149 and see what happens so
set your neighbors to 149 your neighbors
is 31 set it to 149 yes
can you say it again please yes um when
you see classes are you talking about
the feature set the features like you
gave the diagram you saw the you have
three different classification yes right
so three class classification so in that
if you have like if you put k equal to
33 still you can have like ah yes right
the problem will give 1111 love it yeah
yeah so thank you it's due plus it's
fine but I see what you mean thank you
did you change the neighbors to 149 yes
and what did you get 20 okay also 149
gives you two if we set our neighbors to
149 let's check this give me one moment
please
the reason why you get two classes is
because there's less green than red and
blue so the amount of your test data is
overwhelmed the amount of your red and
blue test day is actually overwhelming
degree and if you notice because you
have distance green is closer than the
red and blue so that's why you have a
decision point which is green as well
okay this section of the presentation is
finished are there any other questions
before we go on to the second part
I am Not sure that something i would
have to try out and write down any other
questions no silence now it's time for
the second part of our presentation
references okay now what I don't know
about you but personally I am I go to a
lot of conferences and I go to a lot of
meetup groups I learn a skill i
sometimes do it well during the actual
session but then after the session or
after the class I never pick it up again
and or I pick it up six months later and
i'm going to try to stop that from
happening today so I can't help I can't
talk about time management I mean that's
up to you but I can give you a
suggestion on where to go to now if you
want to improve on machine learning or
if you want to find more machine
learning problems helpful hints are not
beyond the scope of this presentation if
you want to know more what we're going
to do today is oh wow that's not there
these are the blogs that I look at I
stalk people if you have a blog if you
have information on pandas or
scikit-learn I will be looking for you
and I'll be citing you so that's one way
that go about it and the second way is
cattle have you ever heard of cattle
before think most of you have yes cattle
is great I've started cattle about two
or three weeks ago when I'm learning a
new skill i usually make my own product
or project
I contribute to open source but cattle
is another way that you can learn a
skill and it's just another option so
what we're going to do today is we're
actually going to start on a cattle
problem so I'm going to do an
introduction on what cattle is and then
I have another notebook that's dedicated
to the tight antic data set that we're
going to start today
so for those who do not know Kaggle
cackles basically machine learning
competitions can you see that and the
good thing about the great thing about
kagal is not only are you practicing
different algorithms but you have
different motives like you can crack you
can go into a competition and you can
compete for money you can compete for a
job or you can go to a university um
which university has data sets and you
can play around with their data set and
learn more about different algorithms so
what we're doing today is we are going
to look at the Titanic data set so what
I would like you to do is let's see give
me a moment kagal Titanic excellent
so there are two things one if you can
navigate to the cattle tight antic
getting started go to get data and you
will be testing and training based on
the data files before you actually get
into the machine learning part could you
open the cattle ipython notebook there
are six challenges so I'd like you to
spin the remaining part of the time
working on the six challenges using this
data set and this is a good way for you
to get started with cattle so I'll leave
you some time to do that now which one
give me a mine
underscore
oh I'm sorry
previous one but um it is am I getting
hit by lab for these um enough for the
first one to know you'll need pantis
yeah the first excuses do pandas
I like honesty hey I'm just around for
help
yeah that's a training and that's also
the testing data and first you're going
you're going to load the TS fees into
your notebook so that's task one
so task 1 is loading your testing and
training data into your notebooks and if
you need any help you could just raise
your hands think you would have to get
that separately do you have matplotlib
Conte is the best way to go like I tried
hip install and I've gotten a lot of
dependency issues actually I can look
that up excuse me
you
I think you need download from there
yeah then I went in signing
okay well first you go to the first
you're gonna do sense okay and it's a
nerve where is the directory of your
ipython notebook so you're going to put
your data sets in the same directory as
your notebook right
woman oh um I didn't it didn't let you
know this but if you look in my github
repo there's actually a readme sheet
it's not a cheat sheet but it's
different like you can go to help you of
the questions I'm also wondering in my
notebook setup is right because this can
I see sometimes when you're using my
Python you have to go back / / pylab in
the notebook okay that's something I've
learned like two days of them Oh
wait a second so where are your
notebooks here so I'd with idea
you're not getting in a row for
which of my computer
you
so try this it would be notebook ipython
notebook / elastic pylab equals in line
yeah let's have this question I Python
okay um you said we were supposed to
collect yes just it's in a folder in the
same directory as your notebook yeah I
can't they seem to navigate within my
directories okay right all right we're
going to finish up in the next four
minutes or so so if there are any more
questions now is your chance
Hey oh say it again oh ok everything
clear yeah just making sure you know
about what did I tected wonderful if
you're Amish Krishna's Shonka did a
great hike on um tutorial on Titanic and
kagal it's three hours long but it's the
best tutorial it's three hours well
spent yeah oh it's actually
so if you want more information about
Kaggle and the data set I would suggest
looking at Krishna zonkers presentation
on cattle cattle and data science it's
three hours long one the best three
hours that you can spend looking at a
tutorial it was presented at PyCon 2014
and that information the slides and the
video should be in a repo it's in
today's repo that I gave you
okay um this is the end of the
presentation thank you for joining and I
hope you continue with cattle and
scikit-learn